rather than being felt decades into the
future will arrive much much sooner
and mr speaker this unprecedented
commitment to build a world-class
railway that delivers for passengers and
freight for towns and cities for
communities and businesses
will benefit eight out of ten of those
busiest rail corridors across the north
and the middles providing faster
journeys increased capacity more
frequent services up to 10 years sooner
than previously planned
and mr speaker when i became transport
secretary in 2019 the hs2 project was
already about 10 years old it was
concerned i was concerned the costs were
rising the newer projects like the
midlands rail hub the northern
powerhouse rail hadn't been fully
factored into those plans and under the
original scheme the hs2 track would not
have reached the east midlands and the
north until the early 2040s
clearly a rethink was needed to make
sure the project would deliver for the
regions that it served as soon as
possible and this is how the integrated
rail plan was born a desire to deliver
sooner and so the prime minister and i
asked douglas okabe to lead that work
and make recommendations on the best way
forward one of the key criticisms was
that hs2 was designed in isolation from
the rest of the transport network the
original plans gave us high-speed lines
to the east midlands but it didn't serve
any of the three biggest east midland
cities for example
if you wanted to get to nottingham or
derby you'd still have to go to parkway
station and change onto a local tram or
train
okavy made clear and a very convincing
case for considering that hs2 as part of
an integrated rail plan should work
alongside local regional and national
services not just those traveling
between our biggest cities
but so we accepted those recommendations
and asked the national infrastructure
commission to develop options
the commission came back with two key
suggestions first that we adopt a
flexible approach initially setting out
a core integrated rail network but that
we remain open to future additions as
long as expectations and costs and
timing were met
second that strengthening regional rail
links would be most economically
beneficial for the north and the
midlands connecting towns with main
railway networks bringing hope and
opportunity to communities who for too
long felt left behind and that we should
bring these benefits to passengers and
local economies as soon as possible
these then were the guiding principles
behind the integrated rail plan that i'm
announcing today it's an ambitious and
unparalleled program that not only
overhauls the inter-city links across
the north and middles but it also speeds
up the benefits for local areas and
serves destinations people most want to
reach
mr speaker this new blueprint delivers
three
high-speed lines first that's crew to
manchester second birmingham to the east
midlands with hs2 trains continuing to
central nottingham and central derby
chesterfield and sheffield on an
upgraded main
and third a brand new high-speed line
from warrington to manchester and to the
western border of yorkshire slashing
journey times across the north
mr speaker
mr speaker
well
mr big i know they'll want to hear the
detail
of those journey times and they'll also
want to explain
why their constituents would wish to
wait
would wish to wait decades more to
deliver a journey almost no faster at
all than these plans today so mr speaker
i've heard some people say uh that we're
we're just going about and this is i
think their point electrifying uh the
trans-pennine route this is wrong what
we're actually doing is investing 23
billion pounds to deliver northern
powerhouse rail and the transparent
route upgrade unlocking east-west travel
across the north of england so in total
this package is 110 miles of new high
speed line
all of it in the midlands and the north
it's 180 miles of newly electrified line
all of it in the midlands and the north
i just remember remind the honourable
gentleman of their 63 miles of
electrified line in 13 years
we'll upgrade the east coast main line
with a package of investment on track
improvements and digital signaling
bringing down journey times between
london leeds darlington newcastle and
edinburgh bringing benefits to the
northeast much much sooner than under
the previous plans and adds capacity and
speeds of services
over more than 400 miles of lines the
vast majority of it in the midlands and
the north
we'll study how best to take hs2 trains
into leeds as well and we'll start work
on the new west yorkshire mass transit
system
righting the wrong
of this major city probably the largest
in europe which doesn't have a mass
transit system we commit today to
supporting west yorkshire combined
authority over the long term to ensure
that this time it actually gets done
in short mr speaker we're about to
embark on one of the biggest single acts
of leveling up of any government in
history
well listen to the numbers well listen
to the numbers it's five times more than
was spent on crossrail it's ten times
more than was spent on delivering the
olympics but they still think it's a
small package mr speaker
it will achieve the same similar or
faster journey times to london and on
the core northern powerhouse network
than the original proposals and will
bring the benefits years earlier as
double in some case cases triple the
capacity so let me just set out a few of
these investments
rail journeys between birmingham and
nottingham cut from an hour and a
quarter to 26 minutes city center to
city centre journeys between york and
manchester down to 55 minutes from 83
minutes today commuters will be able to
get from bradford to leeds in just 12
minutes almost half the time it takes
today there'll be earlier benefits for
places like sheffield and chesterfield
trips from newcastle to birmingham will
be slashed by almost 30 minutes and
passengers in durham and darlington will
benefit from smoother more reliable
trains as the irp delivers not just for
our largest cities but also for smaller
places and towns for example kettering
market harbor leicester loughborough
grantham newark redford doncaster
wakefield gooseberry huddersfield
stanley bridge they could all see
improvements electrification faster
services benefiting
in ways that they would not have done
under the original hs2 program mr
speaker we're not stopping there today's
plan is about those places which connect
and interact with hs2 and northern
powerhouse rail so the scale of ambition
with many of these projects
lying outside of the scope so just
yesterday i opened the first beaching
reversal
reversing the beaching axe uh and we are
going to be doing the same in
northumberland from washington blithe
newcastle line and many others we're
investing two billion in cycling water
walking three billion uh in turn up and
go bus services and tens of billions in
our country's roads so mr speaker after
decades of decline
uh with constrained capacity and poor
reliability finally this plan will give
passengers and the north and the
midlands the service they need and they
deserve
it's not just about infrastructure we're
going to make train travel much easier
as well today i can confirm
million pounds to reform fares and
ticketing with the roll out of
contactless pay-as-you-go ticketing to
700 urban stations including 400 in the
north mr speaker this is a landmark plan
far by far by far the biggest
of any network improvement and focused
on the north and midlands with more
seats more frequent services shorter
journeys meets the needs of today's
passengers and the future generations
and we're getting started immediately
today with another 625 million pounds
for the electrification between
liverpool manchester and leeds bringing
the total on the tru to 2 billion pounds
and counting and 249 million pounds to
further electrify the midland main line
between catering and market harbor with
work starting on the integrated rail
plan by christmas mr speaker communities
of every size right across the north in
the midlands in many cases years earlier
than planned will benefit by taking a
fresh look at hs2 and how it fits with
the rest of the rail system we'll be
able to build a much improved railway
we'll provide similar or better services
to almost every destination than the
outdated vision drawn up for hs2 over a
decade ago this plan will bring the
north and the midlands closer together
it will fire up economies to rival
london and the south east it will
rebalance our economic geography it will
spread opportunity it will level up the
country it will bring benefits at least
a decade or more earlier and mr speaker
i commend this statement to the house
we now come to shadow secretary of state
jim mcmahon
[Applause]
mr speaker can i thank the secretary of
state for advanced site of this
statement and we'll be uh going out
shortly to collect the actual plan and
to scrutinize it are frankly staggered
by the way this statement started
that he was proud to present this to the
house
proud of what
the betrayal of trust the betrayal of
promises and the betrayal of investment
the north of england and the midlands
deserve
mr speaker we've all seen the reports
over the weekend each one setting out
the betrayal being put forward today
and there's no amount of gloss no matter
spin that can be put on this
he promised hs2 to leads he promised
northern powerhouse rail he promised
that the north would not be forgotten
but it hasn't just forgotten us he's
completely sold us out
as somebody who lives in greater
manchester i'm not going to take
lectures on what northern powerhouse
rail means we know exactly what it means
we were committing to a new line
connecting manchester and leeds
and within a month of becoming prime
minister boris johnson said i'm going to
deliver on my commitment with a pledge
to fund leads to manchester
we were promised a new line mr speaker
he's broken that promise
and he hasn't even got the decency to
admit it
mr speaker let's be clear the scaling
back a northern powerhouse rail coupled
with a scrapping of the eastern leg of
hs2 is a massive blow for our regions
both schemes would have created 150 000
new jobs connecting 13 million people in
our major towns our cities and our
industrial heartlands
it was the then chancellor george
osborne who first announced the northern
powerhouse rail in 2014.
since then the conservatives including
the prime minister including the
transport secretary have recommitted and
re-promised 60 times
this is a once in a generation chance to
transform opportunity across our whole
country rebalancing the economy and
making it work for working people but
that opportunity now looks set to be
lost
and it's the very same working people
that will likely face a record increase
when rail fares go up next year
they'll be paying 50 more to get to work
than they did a decade ago
relying on a crumbling unreliable and
overcrowded system that prioritizes
profit above passengers
and it's the same with buses fares up 70
use down and not a single one of the
four thousand zero emission buses
promised by the prime minister now three
years ago not a single one delivered
and what's on offer
96 billion pound that we should be
grateful for but let's unpack that
96 billion pound 40 billion pound of
which has already been committed from
london to crew
but is being labeled as investment
across the north of england and of the
56 billion pound that remains let's
compare that to what the north of
england would have got over the last
decade had had the same investment as
london and the southeast and we're still
10 billion pound short
we are not going to accept crumbs off
the table
labor would reform our transport
networks so they work for working people
with investments spread more evenly
across the country so that parents
aren't forced to see their children
leave the places where they were raised
only to find opportunity that is denied
on their own doorstep
most importantly labor will put working
people first using the power of
government and the skill of business to
ensure good quality jobs are created
here in britain and in every single
region
madam deputy speaker
boris johnson was elected on a promise
to level the playing field
to make things better for households
across the country
we were promised a northern powerhouse
we were promised a midlands engine to be
leveled up
but what we've been given today is a
great train robbery
robbing the north of his chance to
realise his full potential robbing the
next generation of the hope and the
opportunity they are due and robbing 50
million people across the north of the
investment that they've been denied for
11 years under this rotten government
[Applause]
madam deputy speaker
i just want to make sure i understand
the the honourable gentleman's uh
approach to this his lines as it were
because
96 billion pounds of expenditure the
single biggest ever investment and we
haven't we haven't made we haven't made
any secret of the fact that some of that
money is already the birmingham to crew
line the crew to manchester line last
time i checked that benefits the
midlands and north doesn't it that
actually is help and i realized that he
wrote his uh response there before
actually hearing uh what was in the
statement or decided to ignore it
because there's a brand new high-speed
line from warrington so i just want to
check the the geography from warrington
to manchester to west of yorkshire in
marsden and yet he doesn't think that
that exists by his response but i'll
tell you overall what actually confuses
me the most of all the most of all by
this it's that the uh the the uh lead
the leader of the opposition seems to be
in a completely separate place and i
quote the leader of the opposition said
i oppose hs2 on cost and merit so he
opposes hs2 he will not achieve its
stated objectives but just for
transparency he did say that in 2015
what's he been saying more recently he
says the government should take this
opportunity to cancel hs2 this is the
leader of the opposition saying it so
before the honourable gentleman gets
carried away why doesn't have a word
with the leader of his party and work
out whether they actually agree with his
position on this because this is an
enormous investment it will create three
new high-speed lines it electrifies
track uh and uh just today nearly 400
miles of track electrification is
announced within these programs what a
contrast madam deputy speaker with the
63 miles of track they managed to
electrify in 13 years in office and i
just want to i just want to finish by
talking about the importance of the
overall transport uh approach because
this isn't just about rail as the
honourable gentleman rightly points out
it's also about other means of getting
around you can't get around without a
roads program we have a 20 billion plus
road building program
they oppose it they don't want to build
any roads i'm not sure where he wants to
run these buses he keeps talking about
but i have already written to him and i
think i'm right in saying uh sent the
letter to the library of the house
because he will continue to go around
saying of these 4 000 buses none are on
the road that is factually untrue i've
written to him with the detail
900 of those buses are ordered many of
them already on the road i know that it
is the opposition's job to oppose but if
he is already opposing his opposition
leader then no wonder they don't have a
cohesive transport policy
chairman of the transport select
committee hugh merriman
mr speaker thank you the prime minister
promised that hs2 and northern
powerhouse
rail was not an either or option
and those in leeds and bradford may be
forgiven for viewing it today as neither
this is the danger in selling perpetual
sunlight
and then leaving it for others to
explain the arrival of moonlight
because on a standalone basis
this plan comprises some fantastic
projects that will slash journey times
and better connect our great northern
cities and for that the transport team
deserve much credit my question
it costs us in this country two million
pounds to deliver a single kilometer of
electrified track the germans can do
this for under 500 000 pounds because
they have a rolling program of
electrification
what steps is the secretary of state
taken to ensure this new plan can be
delivered to time and to this cost
thank you uh madame dev to speaker and
uh my honourable friend's absolutely
right the uh improvements in journey
times for example bradford which has
been talked about a great deal 12
minutes from bradford to leeds what we
called for what everyone was calling for
is a london southeast style connectivity
12 minutes between two of the north's
great cities as a result of this plan is
one of those uh potential uh upgrades
not potential it's in the plan one of
those upgrades
my own friend is absolutely right about
the cost of electrification a lot of
these things seem to cost a lot more in
this uh in this country my humble friend
the rail minister is carrying out an
electrification challenge uh to bring
the sector in and challenge them to
build on electrification much faster
than currently happens and of course we
also have in addition to electrification
uh zero carbon trains electric trains
and hydrogen trains like the hydroflex
which will also help to resolve some of
the more difficult to electrify areas
though as i say we've got full fat
electrification on nearly 400 miles of
road as a result of today's plan
snp spokesperson gavin newlands thank
you very much madam deputy speaker and i
thank the secretary of state for
advanced site of the statement although
i did read most of it in the newspaper
uh beforehand um but i do admire the
secretary of state's hutzpah for the
most bullish u-turn i've yet seen in
this place and he talks of of beaching
reversals this is nothing but an hs2
reversal
and bit by bit hs2 and its grand vision
for a real network i mean actually
belong
in the 21st century rather than the 19th
century as being salami sliced until all
that's left is our birmingham to london
shuttle with a few token services to
manchester benefiting few but costing is
all perhaps the secretary should ask the
french government for some tips on how
their high-speed rail network now two
thousand eight hundred kilometers long
of the germans with over 3000 kilometers
denmark is building high-speed rail to
link with germany's network including an
11-mile tunnel under the baltic sea
meanwhile the uk can't even manage
linking itself
and on electrification the 2015
manifesto
um promised electrification to
windermere south wales and the midlands
and they will ditch so forgive me uh
if we are skeptical that today's
promises will not meet the same fate and
for a country that started the railway
age and produced bernal stevenson and
joseph locke england is now badly badly
served by its transport leadership a
leadership that no number of glossy
reports and reviews can paper over and
so can ask them what implications this
will have for bandit consequences for
both whales and scotland wales now
receive its fair share of funding if hs2
money has been redeployed elsewhere and
can he confirm that ban that will also
apply to scotland's funding given the
scottish government miles ahead of the
uk on decarbonisation electrification
and active travel at least we know
something useful will be done with that
cache and perhaps it's time that
levelling up applied to the dft move the
department up to newcastle kalyal or
doncaster and quickly find out what
level the rest of england operates when
giving it given a shoestring to on a
public transport network that is in the
21st century in theory only
experiencing a third class network the
north of england is expected to endure
every day as compared to that in greater
london might sharpen a human to the dfd
as to whether priorities might lie in
the future
thank you uh
deputy speaker well as you know the
treasury is is going to darlington and
dft has actually gone to leeds and
birmingham we've already got 70 staff up
at our uh leeds office and they're going
to be delighted to be able to travel
around much faster as a result of uh
this plan today i should mention it
involves 12.8 billion pounds
of upgrade of the eastern core so this
is the this is this is upgrading the
east coast uh mainline uh digital
signaling and the like we're not uh near
capacity uh on those routes yet so 12.8
billion pounds will help with the
journey up the east coast of course the
plan also today confirms the west coast
uh update uh of uh the hs2 part of it
rather meaning that um journeys to uh to
uh scotland will be a great deal faster
as a result so there are lots of
benefits uh when it comes to scotland
for bringing these journey times way
down as a result of this investment in
hs2 and this plan today delivers on that
martin vickers
uh thank you madam deputy speaker
i welcome the secretary of state's
statement which i think was a
good balance between uh what uh was
hoped for and what can actually be
achieved i'm sure it was an oversight
that he didn't mention clee thoughts in
his statement and uh can he assure can
he assure me that the uh restored direct
link between klee thorpes and king's
cross which is in the lner draft
timetable will uh indeed begin hopefully
next year but certainly by 2023 and can
you assure me that the east west freight
corridor from the humber ports is still
a priority
my friend i thank my uh honorable friend
he's absolutely right i missed it out of
my forward and i apologize cleethorpe
certainly should get a a mention we are
working my uh humble friend the rail
minister on a klingford uh service uh
potentially uh direct uh to london and
with regards to the uh ports i was
actually visiting uh just a week or two
ago
and know the importance of uh the
connectivity with those ports
hillary pen
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker
the prime minister repeatedly promised
that hs2 and northern powerhouse rail
would be built
in
full
today that promise has been broken
and
leads in the north have been betrayed
could the minister explain insofar as i
understand
the details yet to read the the the um
full report
what is the logic
in taking hs2 from birmingham to east
midlands parkway
building as i understand it a new
high-speed line from leeds to sheffield
but leading a huge great big hole in the
middle
that would have victorian railway
engineers scratching their heads in
disbelief to save well the time says
10.3 billion pounds
what is the purpose in doing that
well madame devastate speaker i think i
can reassure the right honourable
gentleman as much as
one of the purposes of uh northern
powerhouse rail which we are delivering
is to slash the journey times for
example from leeds to manchester we will
deliver exactly that we will provide a
journey time of 33 minutes from leeds to
manchester a significant very
significant improvement as you'll know
but that's not just the that's not the
only thing we'll also cut the journey
times from leeds to london uh to an hour
uh 53 uh birmingham will be an hour and
a half so the all of these journey times
will be coming down dramatically because
of the steps that we're taking today and
not only that we've also announced 100
million pounds
to look at the best way to run the hs2
trains into leeds as well as to sort out
a very long-term problem which is that
leeds doesn't have a mass transit system
uh i think the biggest uh
city in europe without one there have
been many attempts before
we know that over the years this time we
intend to make sure it's followed
through so i think there's a lot for
leads in this uh package and it includes
as it happens uh getting northern
powerhouse rail to run to leeds and i
hope the honourable gentleman's
constituents will feel it benefits them
prosperity across keithley and indeed
the whole of the bradford district is
something which i care deeply about but
of course this is linked to creating
better transport connectivity so i have
to say madam deputy speaker that i am
deeply disappointed by today's
announcement the bradford district has
been in my view completely short changed
we are one of the most socially deprived
parts of the uk and we must get better
transport connectivity and i still want
to see northern powerhouse rail
delivered with a main stop in bradford
so we can unlock our economic
opportunities so can my right honourable
friend explain to the house what the
government is doing to deliver better
more reliable and cheaper rail services
for my constituents in keithley
thank you madam deputy speaker well look
let me just make sure that my honourable
friend uh understands and appreciates
the full relevance of today
12-minute journey 12-minute journey from
bradford to leeds that's
nearly half of the current journey time
30 minutes off
and probably at least 30 minutes off the
bradford to london journey after these
upgrades are complete and unlike the
plans which were not fleshed out at all
i know that transport for the north and
other people have talked about building
all sorts of different versions of this
but one of their versions was indeed
the upgrade of the tru the problem with
these other plans is
no disrespect to my humble friend he may
well not have been an mp in 2043 or
maybe he will have been uh to see those
things delivered these advantages that
i'm talking about this 12 minute journey
the 30 minute off the
the bradford to london journey uh those
will be delivered uh in his first couple
of terms as a member of parliament
catherine mckinley
thank you madam deputy speaker
the secretary of state knows fine well
that the promised integrated
infrastructure investment is about
capacity as much as
travel times and they're just not being
straight as they're asking northerners
to put up with make do and mend rather
than the infrastructure we were promised
is it because the government continues
to see the north as a problem to solve
rather than an opportunity
to invest in and isn't this just another
broken promise from this prime minister
and chancellor who have seemingly
cancelled leveling up because there are
tories on the line it appears the prime
minister is once again driving a train
into the ditch off the truck on his way
to the north
madame deputy speaker listening to the
honorable lady
you would think i'd just come to this
dispatch box to announce that newcastle
for example will have a longer journey
uh to london for example the answer is
exactly the opposite because of these
plans i'm announcing today the journey
from newcastle to london will be 21
minutes shorter you would have thought
she'd be standing up and welcoming
today's massive uh investment into the
train services which will benefit her
constituents and even if she doesn't
appreciate it i rather suspect our
constituents will
andrew jones thank you very much deputy
speaker and can i thank my honourable
friend for this statement i look forward
to reading the detail of the plan
he has given us a complex statement
because there are many changes to
existing plans but it's absolutely clear
that no government has ever invested on
this scale
and he should not listen to any lesson
from the party opposite who did nothing
on the issue
but however please can he detail a bit
more on the time skills for the delivery
specifically when will people in
yorkshire be able to take advantage of
the enhanced services that he's talking
about and can he comment a little bit
further as well on the environmental
benefits and particularly thinking about
the improved clearances for rail freight
madame uh deputy speaker just actually
on the environmental uh advantages or
interests of the house to know that of
course with hs2 it's been built in
environmentally friendly way as possible
section 2b west is actually intended to
be a net positive uh carbon contribution
uh not just in its running but in its
entire life cycle which is going to be
very uh important i thought i'd prefer
the house and my honourable friend to
pages one three four and one three five
which contains a full time scale for
when the various different benefits will
arrive at different locations in every
case
these advantages will start arriving
much much sooner than under the original
plans and for all those people who say
we just should have carried on plowing
on with the original hs2 plan they then
need to explain why it was right to wait
to the 2040s for their constituents to
fill the benefits this way the benefits
will be started to be felt uh by this
christmas where the work gets underway
on the midland main line and is already
underway on the trans-pennine route
liam byrne
thank you madam speaker i just want to
follow up with my vulnerable friend for
lead central i just want to understand
the new east-west division that the
secretary of state has set out today so
as i understand it constituents our
constituents moving from leeds to
manchester will travel by high-speed
train
south of leeds then change trains to get
a train to nottingham parkway
and then get on a new high-speed train
from nottingham parkway to birmingham i
think that's what the secretary of state
has set out but mr speaker since we
approved this planning cabinet china has
built 23 and a half thousand miles of
high-speed line
this tory government has built none
we've had a review every year he's just
destroyed the plans but hundreds of
millions of pounds in birmingham is
predicated on being at the heart of a
network not a mishmash how can we now
believe the plan that he set out yeah
i should point out madam deputy speaker
that china uh do not have the same
health and safety approach as us they
don't they have a slightly different
view of how many people it's acceptable
to kill per mile of uh track laid and i
don't think he's seriously considering
uh we go down that route i know that he
represents a birmingham constituency i
know that the mayor of the west midlands
has widely broadly welcomed this package
birmingham does it very well out of it
the connection which wasn't initially
envisaged within the hs2 plan between
the biggest cities in the midlands
birmingham and nottingham for example
will now be complete with not just a
parkway station but stations into the
city centre of nottingham into the city
centre of derby and connecting uh
birmingham so it's going to be fantastic
news for his constituents he asked about
trains no people won't be changing the
trains uh they'll be on the same train
all the way through the path
so william cash
i did not hear the secretary of state
mention the stretch
between birmingham and crew which cuts
straight through my constituency from
top to bottom causing massive misery to
my constituents
uh what would my with my right
honourable friend uh confirm that
discussions have taken place to improve
the situation
and will he and his minister of state
commit to continue
to listen to the proposed solutions
which would mitigate and this misery and
help to solve the problems faced by my
constituents
well it's absolutely right that hs2 has
had a big impact on a lot of communities
or does as it uh as it is built um and
of course the advantages in different
places are uh different for different
members and their constituents and so
i'm absolutely uh delighted to assure my
right honourable friend that he can
continue to work with the hs2 minister
who has done wonders to improve uh the
relationship between the communities and
try to bring some benefits even where
there aren't stops necessarily to
communities along the hs2 line uh
through some of the community funds and
other things and i'll recommit that uh
to my honourable friend today
dame diana johnson yeah yeah
thank you madam deputy speaker it was
five years ago on tuesday since tory
ministers blocked the privately financed
rail electrification to hull
and not one mentioned today of the great
city of the north hull and the
economically important area of the
humber
now can the secretary of state explain
why passengers in hull who pay more for
their train tickets and get a poorer
service
will have to wait even longer now
because i can't see anything in the
detail of the prime minister delivering
on his promise for northern powerhouse
rail in the in the hull and the humber
area leveling up means absolutely
nothing
as the honourable lady be right if we're
going to leave that statement there from
the transport secretary uh in spite of
his claim that he will
uh the government's new plans will
result in
faster journey at times across the
network and he says 110 miles of new
high-speed track and 180 new miles of
electrified line it's fair to say that
the reception on both sides of the house
was pretty
poor the big concern is that the
link going up to leeds uh is no longer
going to be there from hs2 and also that
there is not going to be a new line
between leeds and manchester so
very unhappy particularly mps on both
sides from bradford and leeds well with
me is our political correspondent
uh rob powell rob why
has the government which
promised repeatedly
uh to do both those things the uh have a
new line between manchester and leeds
and also
to have uh hs2 going east why has the
government cancelled all this i think
partly it's because of time and partly
because of money time wise you heard
from grant chaps there that he wants to
try and accelerate the delivery of this
and
they believe that by concentrating
partly on new track but partly on
upgrading existing track they can as
they see it anyway bring the benefits
sooner uh than it would have under the
original hs2 plan and then partly money
as well because uh the northern power
has partnerships done the sums on this
and has found that they are taking a
considerable amount um out of what they
originally promised i think we're going
to need to see some of the detail about
what these exact plans will mean not
just for journey times but also for
capacity as well because as you say
there's three main announcements that
the government have made the first as
expected was the crew to manchester hs2
line which will go ahead then we find
out that the full eastern leg of hs2
that was supposed to run up through an
east midlands hub near nottingham that
will carry on but then uh there will be
hs2 trains on existing track going up to
sheffield and then just the promise of a
study to find out how to get high speed
um into leeds and then on that um
east-west link what sometimes called
northern powerhouse
rail that will not be a completely new
track between manchester and leeds there
will only be new track running from
warrington through manchester to marsden
in west yorkshire and then there will be
upgrades on the the rest of the track
now the government says on that east
west link actually in terms of journey
times it'll only be two or three minutes
um slower than originally planned and
they're also claiming as well that
they'll be double capacity as well i
think that's the
part of this that on the whole is
getting people wondering about how you
can still deliver on vastly increased
capacity without building completely new
lines because the problem with running
fast trains and slow trains on the same
line
is that you do get issues with capacity
and if you can segregate the lines and
put the high speed trains down one line
and the stopping services the slower
trains on another line you get
substantial increases on capacity so i
think that promise of whether capacity
can be doubled um running um across from
manchester to le to leeds is something
we will need to look at in the
integrated rail rail plan um when that's
published i haven't seen it online yet
i've only got a press release um as it
stands in terms of the reaction you did
hear stormy reaction from both sides um
i think
there may well be some it's not going to
notice that some of the originally
planned eastern leg of the high speed
line would run through a lot of newly
won conservative seats without them
seeing much benefit of it so you wonder
whether that counters in whether that
will factor into the political
calculation on the part of the
government the danger i guess is that if
the headline from this is that this is
not what was promised this is less than
what is promised it doesn't look good
for their promises on leveling up worth
noting that the conservative mph
merriman who is the chair of the
transport select committee
has criticized the government saying
this is the danger of selling perpetual
sunlight
and leaving it to someone else to
explain moonlight
well john is now is the former chair of
the
national infrastructure commission also
of course former labour transport
secretary uh andrew adonis lord of
donors noah dennis thank you very much
indeed for being with us
uh what do you make of these new plans
for rail in the north of england from
the government
well it's a betrayal of the promises
that the government made to the north of
england because they were going to get
high-speed rail going both to manchester
and to leeds